and like ron desantis other republican
leaders are no longer content to just
sit back play defense and let the left
dominate this cultural battle space
missouri attorney general eric schmidt
just launched a portal where parents can
upload disturbing materials their kids
may be being taught
what he's found thus far has been
nothing short of shocking attorney
general schmidt joins me now i want to
begin
with something called the gender unicorn
and apparently it covers gender identity
gender expression
whom you're attracted to among other
things now it seems like this is made
for younger kids being with unicorns
what grades is this being assigned to
yeah this is a part of the training
materials that teachers would use in the
classroom for younger kids and it
doesn't stop there laura you've got the
oppression matrix that whistleblowers
have brought forward where students are
divided by the oppressor and the
oppressed a white supremacy pyramid
where if you believe that people should
be judged by the content of their
character and not the color of their
skin that is covert white supremacy
there's a power and privilege
wheel that students in seventh grade are
meant to look at there's a 16-19 project
grant application that's part of
the curriculum in a school district of
missouri and ultimately this is about
parents have every right laura to know
what's being taught in the classroom
sadly a lot of school districts across
the country and in missouri don't
believe that so this is an effort to
empower parents and bring transparency
to the curriculum okay let me just say
this is a brilliant idea and i'm so
upset that it wasn't done sooner but
better late than never
um because again parents are so busy
uh general schmidt that you know they're
just hoping they can get their kids to
school and get to work and put dinner on
the i mean they're all stressed out so
they're not boring into the material uh
oftentimes but now they are including
this chart that you referenced
understanding white supremacy now it
included a list of of things i believe
that are covert white supremacy
including make america great again
uh police murdering people of color
that's terrifying assuming that good
intentions are enough celebration of
columbus day
that's uh triggering and
anti-immigration policies and practices
so actually having a border uh saying
but just one human family color
blindness not challenging racist jokes
denial of white privilege
eric make america great again and a
number of those things were bizarre
this is nuts laura and by the way that
came from materials in the largest
school district in missouri in
springfield missouri now we've sued them
to uncover more documents because they
don't want to give us the rest of that
that was whistleblowers coming forward
so we've already launched a lawsuit
against that school district but to your
point laura during the lockdowns i think
parents heard some things while kids
were home that they couldn't believe
they started showing up to school board
meetings to object to that enforced
masking policies then what happened the
department of justice worked with the
national school boards association to
weaponize the fbi to go after parents as
domestic terrorists under the patriot
act this is crazy that's out of a third
world country we're also suing the
department of justice to uncover more
documents there and the missouri school
boards association so we're not going
away parents i believe you know need to
be empowered here but as attorney
general we're going to do everything we
can to stick up for parents and kids too
uh this is so
i mean everyone has to go on
my website and i'm going to have more on
this on lauraingram.com because this is
just we don't have enough time to do all
of it but i know we'll have you back
attorney general schmidt thank you
and for leading on this hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else